hello and welcome to the new review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today we are back with some more jiu
jitsu kaisen
wander to review the versus mojito arc
mojito being the name of the dude with
the face which sure is oddly unspecific
but there's really only one character in
the series
so far where you can safely say that his
face is definitely his aesthetic
defining feature in any case this was a
pretty incredible arc that threw a ton
of great stuff our way including yuji's
first proper conflict as a jujutsu
sorcerer the exploration of what seems
to be a fantastic antagonist in majito
as well as the very tragic existence of
junepe plus another thoroughly
captivating presence anonymity this arc
just had me hooked from beginning to end
and we shall begin with the latter
character i mentioned because naomi is a
fantastic addition to this cast he is a
very necessary presence to balance out
the flippant insanity of gojo and i
think it's a huge huge credit to
akutami's writing that he can take a
character with such stern stoic traits
and make nanome every bit as interesting
as someone like gojo it's a lot harder
than it seems to make a cool stern guy
this intriguing mainly because that kind
of personality by their very nature is
heavily reserved with a lot of barriers
preventing readers or watchers from
getting to know them beyond a
superficial level as opposed to the more
goofy lovable loudmouths and akatami
does this so simply as well i really did
immediately connect with anonymity right
from the get-go because he says so
little but what little he does express
is very efficient none of his words or
actions are wasted and you get a very
clear picture of him almost immediately
and on top of that a pretty fantastic
design a very intriguing
style of sorcery and we have a nigh on
perfect character perfect in the sense
of wanting to be invested in him not
necessarily his beliefs and actions
which speaking of like gojo anonymity is
a clear revolutionary in the making he
has an extreme distaste for the current
global system which he expressed in a
more social manner there was a very cool
flashback showcasing how empty his life
was managing money of the rich and how
he saw humble bakeries as far more
important to society at large but even
without the flashback we had a clear
picture of him pretty much immediately
after he said well jiu-jitsu sorcerers
they're idiots but working in an office
is idiotic so i chose the lesser of two
evils which is a great example of what i
mean by efficient that really did tell
me everything that his flashback ended
up conveying just with no emotion
attached to it which isn't to say that
the flashback was unnecessary it
definitely wasn't because that emotion
is very very important but it's more of
a credit to akhitami for flawlessly
conveying who this man is without
needing a flashback to do so the
flashback was just the icing on the cake
in delicious
none of me cake and on top of that he
just had so many badass lines throughout
the sock my favorite of which was the
office worker style thread of
it's 5 30. i started work at 10 today so
no matter what
i'm clocking out by six never before has
office language sounded so
wonderfully threatening and i also love
that his office lifestyle has carried
over so strongly into his sorcery as
well i found the overtime condition
particularly interesting because i love
the idea of limiting your powers during
standard work hours in order to
significantly increase your curse
prowess
in the event that one is forced to work
overtime and i also believe he had
another restriction which was to reveal
exactly how his curse technique worked
which
i don't know if this was literally
stated i forget to be honest with you
but surely this once again results in
some sort of power boost for basically
kneecapping himself by giving the
enemies that information
it reminds me a lot of gentry from
hunter hunter who had a very similar
condition where he needed to disclose
exactly how his non-abilities operated
as an activation requirement there's
just something i really love about power
systems where yeah sure you can achieve
high output but you also need to pay an
equal price for that power and the price
that you dear viewer may need to pay is
that of subscribing to the new world
review
which will set a binding vowel granting
regular injections of jujutsukaisen
content administered straight into your
youtube feed a very powerful and highly
advantageous mechanic that simply should
not be ignored but speaking of curse
mechanics and structure get some very
nice expansions here as well during the
arc something that really took my eye is
the idea of the fly heads actually
mostly because i'm glad that we're not
just you know outright neglecting
lower level curses the whole idea of the
great hierarchy kind of spooked me
because i feared that it would be
immediately made
irrelevant but it's nice to see that
there are some genuine and interesting
uses at the very least for these lower
grade existences
i mean putting them to work to find out
if someone is a curse user or not that's
a cool little utility idea that keeps
the lower grades somewhat relevant and i
also quite
bizarrely enjoyed the additional idea of
the sorcerer versus curse grade system
being staggered like it's not as simple
as grade 1 sorcery is equal to grade 1
curse and it makes all the sense in the
world because if your job was to
exterminate these things then why would
you give them an even match up so yes a
grade 2 sorcerer should absolutely wipe
the floor with a grade 2 curse which in
the end isn't all that big of a deal but
it gives the series that tiny bit more
depth the idea that there is this
thoroughly thought out human bureaucracy
at play and the idea that not everything
can be summed up by some nice
neat little system very reminiscent of
real life meanwhile the concept of
residuals is also quite fun because once
again it adds an element of risk to
using cursed energy but along with that
it also adds strategy say if you wanted
to deliberately leave a residual trail
fun stuff to play with as an author i
imagine if you can keep track of it all
but now we're going to move to one hell
of a
crazy mofo being mahito this arc delves
so much more into him than i really
expected things to this early on but he
holds a highly dangerous yet very
interesting philosophy the concept of
life containing no weight
or value and in his mind there is no
limitation on how life
should or could be used for personal
benefit he's very much the anti-yuji who
began the series with the idea that all
life holds value
even those deemed worthless by society
and we'll get to eugene in a bit because
uh yeah but mahito holds a very
appropriate technique for his views
being that he's able to manipulate souls
also
very casual confirmation of the
existence of souls there one of the most
complex discussions in all of humanity
and we've just solved it right here but
what nahito represents is very much
counter to everything that i suppose we
are theoretically
supposed to believe in his values which
does make some sense as he is a cursed
spirit himself born of hatred i believe
what's really interesting though is that
as much as he tells junepei not to be
indifferent mahito himself seems quite
indifferent towards humanity right now
like he definitely doesn't see the value
in life but he also hasn't been shown as
wildly driven to get rid of it either
right now he's just screwing around with
his grotesque experiments having a bit
of fun
and i'm sure that there is a much deeper
drive somewhere because for a creature
born specifically of hatred there's just
got to be something stronger working
which is definitely hinted at because
mahito is pretty directly equated to
gojo
having this sense of superficiality but
also a deep dark well of power which is
also terrifying because he is still
developing
said power i loved his domain expansion
though there was a true sense of dread
when mojito activated
it and i felt for sure that nanome was
going to die especially because that was
the very moment where his flashback was
shown and usually seeing a character's
history
is a pretty good sign that they're about
to die imminently but the sukuna twist
there was a very nice way of dealing
with all of that but now we need to talk
about yuji because he faced
and arguably is still facing quite a
crisis earlier i mentioned that he sees
value in all life but he really did have
to confront that guiding philosophy
right here
and in an intriguing twist for a shona
manga yuji did not quite manage to
overcome it
arguably he didn't overcome it at all
even at the very end of the battle yuji
was hell
bent on killing mahito killing yuji
gasp especially since majito is a cursed
spirit you could say exercising him but
no yuji wanted to
kill him yuji's beliefs failed him and
after witnessing what happened to jinpei
yuji is
is kind of broken and he did kill during
this arc make no mistake there was no
clean way for yuji to get out of this he
is stained from here on out and at this
point all he can really do is reevaluate
where he stands in life or even how he
views life it was a pretty deep and
distressing arc for yuji
and yet another in a growing line of
events where he was pretty much
powerless to save people in the way he
wanted and there's something of a
morbidly charming quality about watching
yuji fail because all of these
experiences are going to add up to
either one glorious climax where he
finally does save someone or
alternatively
in one big moment of self-implosion and
i really do enjoy
not knowing what path we'll end up with
i'm not 100 that this story ends well
for him and if it does i'm not confident
that it will do so without a lot more
pain and suffering pushing him beyond
his breaking point eventually but now to
jinpei and man i feel a little bit sick
just saying his name because
what a tragedy watching his story here
was like seeing a train wreck in slow
motion from all the stuff about his high
school to the really twisted
mentor-mentee relationship that he
formed with majito and ultimately being
pushed over the edge then brought back
briefly by yuji
only to have his life snuffed out for
good and as part of this i also want to
underscore his mother i knew the very
moment she showed up that she was
probably as good as dead
you need to be very careful about
lovable tertiary characters in a series
like this
because chances are they are
deliberately designed to be as likable
as possible within the shortest amount
of time
simply so that you can feel the pain of
their loss and there was also something
very interesting about the way in which
her death was communicated
it wasn't seen on screen it wasn't
stated by another character through
dialogue it wasn't even given by a
narrator it was just reported
in pure prose at the beginning of a
chapter which may sound simple and even
underwhelming but that is very unique
for the manga medium and it gave
jiujitsukai scent a brief moment of this
novelistic magic where peak imagination
was activated especially with the
horrific details of what happened to her
body and that it was found stuffed in a
bed with ice packs like really
excruciatingly detailed stuff that has
no place being conveyed visually i don't
think there's anything akatami could
have drawn that would have been more
powerful than just reading these words
and it's very much making me appreciate
the keen intuition that akatami has for
situations like this because he is
clearly not
afraid to depict brutality but in this
case he knew when to hold back
and how this event would have peak
impact but all in all like i said it's
truly tragic
perfectly set up as well with plenty of
moments of hope one of which was when
yuji and jinpei were bonding over movies
which was also a nice callback to the
previous arc but the whole setup gave me
the very distinct impression that yeah
jinpei's mother she was probably done
for but he might have a chance
jinpe himself could be brought back from
the brink and become a new student at
the jujutsu high school the setup for
that was definitely there but alchemy
took all of that and said
no this is going to be one of those
times when something horrible just
happens there is no last minute
salvation no resurrection or at least
i hope not i guess i don't know for sure
but the general idea is that you're just
going to be served a dish of raw
tragedy so bon appetit and as sad as it
is i do appreciate that because
personally i'm a little scarred and i
feel like i've lost a character with
jinpe and that helps me identify a lot
more with yuji because that would be
exactly what he's feeling although in
his case it would be on a significantly
more extreme level so we had quite a
somber ending to the ark although i
should also note there was plenty of
comedy to be had as well it was quite
well balanced especially with stuff like
yuji stealing the teachers pants but
then even that that teacher gets turned
around on us and hits the audience with
some hard drama right at the end of the
arc on something i haven't mentioned yet
it was also great to see yuji developing
his skills i really like the
introduction of how his cursed energy
works with the whole not being able to
keep up with his superhuman speed
resulting in this bizarre kind of double
strike style effect there's such a nice
simplicity about it but it's also not so
simple that it equates to
hmm i hit you with strong fist now it's
not that there's a bit of nuance to it
which is greatly appreciated and really
the only bad thing to say about this arc
is that there was not
enough panda and by not enough i mean
zero panda
not one panda to be seen that should be
a crime and akutami
should be in prison but that pretty much
does it for this blind review of
jiu-jitsu kaisen's vs mojito arc and
what do you guys think please do leave
your thoughts in the comments below or
even join my discord server and if
you're keen for some more jujutsu
sorcery then please do check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe regular jujutsu
kaiser morbidity delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time